cinnamon toast can pewdiepie you
challenge me for a game of island
invaders yes you must be very brave
prepare well prepare to fight kid I
can't even hear you there background
music so lap all right so we're playing
the official minigames of Minecraft are
you are you in there you are hello you
guys their lives you know life having a
son of a gun okay how do I join all
right if we can make a cobblestone
generator so fast we should be able to
know how to join yeah oh here it is
hi I got it before you did what it will
do a join game I'm gonna be a soldier
yeah damn you got an armor bro damn
we're looking good
gonna be a sucess Oh scared Ken hey
don't be scared you got flames on your
feet but I flames nothing
no I'm assassin and what a plane come on
boy you run one fight I don't know what
we're supposed to do I gotta die die
oh we're shooting TNT not again one life
remaining baby baby yeah yeah later
oh not again oh god I don't have a space
left to stand or use ender pearls if you
just use it as a pro to throw yourself
up oh you did it again you will da oh
maybe not good job no stupid gate no
we're equal were equal were equal equals
oh I was like so Lear some more
difficult
no would be a ghost thing but that I'm a
ghost you see my Cape right now right oh
haha
dude God why do we need some snakeskin
mistakes
hello sticks what I'm not shooting TMT
what is this oh no no I keep dying edit
that out whatever that was edit that huh
[Laughter]
hey
more like Senator throw spell are you
coward Oh bye my kid
bye bye
[Music]
Oh youse are gonna die Yussef in that
damn thing you ain't gonna bye bye oh
I'm in a good spot here I'm gonna get
spy here you're never gonna get ya Oh
Usami stop that I say stop
I shoot so slowly you shoot slope yes
come back to reality
OOP there goes gravity oopy-scoopy pap
oh you're up there what stop climbing
loser I know your tricks I know your
thievery no how's it going Brow's oh
really
well who gets the last laugh first
through night first I'll be dead at the
same time OOP there goes gravity you
they do pretty boop beep oh my god how
are you so good oh where I got a fault
it's a magic star go magic star summon
TNG yeah you think I'm not you'd know
how to utilizing items he's using items
he's cheating ah free break you break
you now
you know I'm done I'm done disconnect
disconnect disconnect oh wait the game
like crashed I woulda shame I guess we
had the same romantic I think I was in
the lead so I think that means I win
alright how about something that I know
you will never beat me in oh ok let's do
that let's do whatever that is that
sounds fun
am i detecting a little bit of an
attitude you don't want to just left the
game because you lost a bit bp9cc sleepy
that's what you sound like
thank you baby and read from fart noises
too
oh yeah well you have big bean match
that's like it I capitalized it for you
date that's a big break will you make a
shirt for freaking everything oh yeah
ranch man I didn't make the Ritz like
the only one oh all right all right I
mean I mean what is this
I wasn't trying to push you off the game
right no no we got it I'm just trying to
get a better angle on these people all
right yeah yeah how long Fricks would I
even be able to right-click him you just
right-click this from here
oh you can just walk to him yeah pick a
team over here on the right okay I'm
gonna be shark team no I'm short team
I'm already short team shark team son I
already picked it like two minutes ago
no all right fine I'm okay okay let's go
okay wait what is this and what we doing
here I can't look at this double capes
you have to I'm waiting I'm wearing that
Electra I don't expect you to know what
that is
all right ready ready up coward ready up
coward maker horse starts in three two
one
epic what do we do this it's called
minecraft week yeah but just hey I want
to change chest but I get in here
someone's gonna die
use a fin and are gonna you gonna what
is it litora how does it feel that I'm
gonna get the chest before you do okay
okay
big brain I'll use your small brain
coming
[Music]
[Laughter]
damn ballast but hey good late
so now let's quit while I'm ahead mine
boat rate let's play like alright your
game
what's up cinnamon toast game new mini
game alright let's try and focus for a
two seconds alright may the best win so
you get to pick a boat
alright pick the blue boat let's see how
do you play the game oh look there's a
look at it it's a big brain it's a big
brain whoa
that's how we do it we hold the brake on
of course you can't use your brain
unless you have it in your hand
science alright you just jump here to
play it says oh you ready to raise in a
minute alright alright through the
jungle and Beyond oh why is my board is
your blue
what okay here we go I'm not in my boat
goodbye loser every disqualifying are
you kidding me oh not bad I have to look
at you as well why you did it Ken
congratulations my boob is Oh next coins
I have next man
they make next map why are you white so
right click and get your freaking boat
this time oh I have to right-click whoa
this is like whoa damn I'm fast
Super Mario do you like that impression
Super Mario you
no I didn't I didn't I poison my rival
oh oh
boys take that even poison oh my god are
you I'm right behind you
[Music]
your brain is small your brain is small
can just realize I'm gonna catch up
don't worry
this reminds me of we back when I was in
high school and we were canoeing and
someone's dad capsized our canoe and we
had to be wet with an entire trip and I
always hated that guy's dad Oh we'll use
the brain on you don't you ever ever use
brain on me okay better turn then you're
blind you blind you have your lime your
lime oh the items are coming left and
right he can't keep up now you can't for
love Ken no now my boat this is not fair
boy service disconnect you left server
disconnect
what a shame that did this connected Ken
what a shame but now we will play a game
that is in my favor
okay coward ready to go Bing bong oh hey
we're back you can't even get up there
how do you expect to challenge me if you
can make a single little jump turn
around like God my god bad boy you
better get ready bebe a word yeah
be worthy a knock you off I knock you
ignore I knock you up and look you are I
know you us goodbye how tall it you're
so you're a lemon squeezer oh how you
fly like this can't you can't like this
scrub oh let me into the water it didn't
work this time Oh me where are you I can
go for the knees 360 okay shut up okay
be too proud go into lava fire go in the
lava yeah why don't you go in the water
can go in the water can dance floor
dance oh the one thing you have
absolutely no chance at winning
whatsoever what you saw my dance moves I
did see your dance movement press from
everyone saw my mom's dance move I think
she danced the entire adventure mode
okay here we go I think you're gonna
like it
oh we're entering we're entering do you
hear music I'm just clicking button Wow
okay look it look it doesn't move can i
buy your look
I was winning by so much sir are you
really well you got below whoa whoa whoa
this is best day ever best day fat dose
start I started it
oh you look down what I can't look
anywhere yeah sky blocks blank sky block
skin we're ready to whip out the
cobblestone generator and half a second
it's a race in the sky my god it's a
race aah
Hector's hurt to my soul uh-oh I still
see jump boost whoa Oh
do a 360 pure man am i running the right
direction
no got my way don't you dare call me new
sir good you're in front of me you want
to hear about scale ken bond would scale
if you put you in front of me because
you already knew I just fall off the map
and like give all for free for free
[Music]
damn I'm fast they call me the fastest
sweet alive a cuff or I am behind you
right now
oh let's see it be put be a problem oh
no I die ease it 1 1 uh me i won all
right I'm gonna go ahead and say you won
again I did only so you don't quit
playing because they're too scared
Oh were you scared of that sound it's
just a video game can remember the first
time we ever game together and they were
like yeah I'm Eric who's like so much
better at platform yeah and as a racist
anybody else what I said that to trick
you the ones I said that to trick you
eight years later so that once we're
playing Minecraft and we're doing a
plaque I'm dead it bounced to be
freaking off great
I go forever and beyond others items the
level to I just saw this you didn't see
the items know what you saw the items
you don't tell me this how dare you I
guess for once you didn't have time to
read the tutorial for three hours all
right I'm just gonna I'm just gonna jump
off I don't know how you died so pretty
quickly last battle can map to me I'll
try to punch you off and it didn't work
in a you were trying to punch your
fellow friend oh well I'll get the items
but then like I can't stay from the
freakin man yeah that's why I said it
you're gonna win this now Ken no it's
all about teamwork I just have to keep
looking at this stupid Swedish cape oh
he called country stupid I love this one
this is fine you like this one let's
change my god if I didn't suck so bad at
it we gotta play one that I can beat you
add which is everyone but this one any
game just pick any game easy all right
hey this is the one we at loser eyes to
tweet from channel what those guys to
tweet can I tweet Taylor Swift again
guard you shouldn't follow you have to
last time no bro alright
it's the bomb Athan it's not just bomb
like that they say to in Swedish tamal
says blowing up man I don't know what I
don't know what do know man oh don't be
scared it's the good luck good luck oh
wait how am I supposed to oh I can jump
over okay I must pull yours up failed I
didn't blow up everything
d12 easy baby
[Laughter]
[Music]
where are you coward
oh you think me in cuz you didn't hit
join I can't wait to get old I'm gonna
be so epic in adult John game
yeah joint game this time I'm lucky
lucky lucky
alright okay this way this time we will
act civilized okay no more silly don't
think so coward how dare you know in a
pro socks yeah run too bad oh how did
you live quiet quiet quiet
oh I'm a new class now
good good job new class you did it oh
you're the ghost
I'm trapped play on easy mode are you
still alive I'm too good no oh my god
again I keep boiling it I hate this game
but I hit everyone for my peepee in your
poop oh oh oh
come at me fool Oh God haha you watched
him what the lemon squeezer God how do
you need me to teach class I am so good
okay I'll pick okay I'll stay what I am
you can't be me my best best
I wasn't utilizing my classes what
those be watching at home right now you
may think this is all funny but he's
really man no don't even care if I if I
cared would I do this stop no don't wait
wait wait wait wait wait I am in the
wrong expectation I wouldn't hurt you if
you didn't anything I wouldn't I
wouldn't hurt anything
yeah are you in there purling no you're
free one right there that's two free
once I guess to the can't lay on the map
yes yes no I have to go that's why can I
told you you're gonna have to go
sorry bro sorry you have to go time time
time has to go bite me do after you
thank you guys so much for watching
don't check out ken and smash like check
out March however well you haven't tried
to personal a turd city after 50 million
outros much now just now it's still
relevant just download it